[Music]
former president martin viscara is among
a group of politicians who secretly got
a coronavirus jab
before anyone else in peru it's been
revealed the vaccine was part of a
supply of around
3 000 sent by chinese pharmaceutical
cinepharm these were in addition to the
12 000 used in a trial
i was never told that there were more
vaccines than the 12 000 of this trial
or that people in my government were
participating i sincerely apologize
dr hermann malega who led the trials and
gave viscara the shot
testified in congress on tuesday the
former president
knew what vaccine he was getting
i told him we had vaccines that were
active
pedu began its vaccination campaign last
week but at least
487 people were quietly inoculated
between september and february the
outgoing foreign minister said
she couldn't afford getting sick the
former health minister said
she was afraid of the virus
i reiterate our anger and disappointment
for learning that many public officials
took advantage of their position
for being immunized with vaccines that
arrive separately to those used in the
clinical trials
the list of beneficiaries included
officials and doctors who weren't part
of the trial
many brought along their wives husbands
in-laws friends
posing as consultants or invitees
these are photos of more than 300
doctors
who lost their lives fighting the
pandemic in addition there are nurses
paramedics hospital workers a long list
of people who've been fighting on the
front line against the coronavirus
who have died without a chance to get a
vaccine
[Music]
the scandal known as vaccine gait has
caused outrage
paul waman whose family is suffering
from covet 19
has been queuing up for days to fill his
tank with oxygen
it's awful because those vaccines are
meant to be for those in intensive care
and people in hospitals are waiting for
those doses
pedus running low on oxygen hospitals
are overwhelmed
more than forty three thousand are dead
but the excess death rate
is more than a hundred and twenty
thousand vaccine gait is now being
investigated by the attorney general
prosecutors and legislators but many in
peru say
it's already clear the group put their
own lives
ahead of others mariana sanchez al
jazeera lima peru